>> WELL, THE MEDIA FAWNS OVER
THE NEWLY SWORN IN LAWMAKERS.
A CONGRESSMAN UNLEASED A PROFANE
RANT CALLING FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
IMPEACHMENT.
>> PEOPLE LOVE YOU AND YOU WIN.
WHEN YOUR SON SAYS MAMMA, WHAT
DO YOU WANT?
BULLIES DON'T WIN.
BABY, THEY DON'T.
WE WILL GO THERE AND IMPEACH THE
[BLEEP].
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> THE FRESHMAN LAWMAKER
STANDING BY HER COMMENT.
>> HER COMMENTS WERE
DISGRACEFUL.
I THINK SHE DISHONORED HERSELF
AND HER FAMILY.
USING LANGUAGE LIKE THAT IN
FRONT OF HER SON AND WHOEVER
ELSE WAS THERE.
THAT WAS A GREAT DISHONOR TO HER
AND THE FAMILY AND DISRESPECTFUL
TO THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID HE BROUGHT
UP IMPEACHMENT WITH SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI TODAY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> WE EVEN TALKED ABOUT THAT
TODAY.
I SAID USE THIS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
NANCY PELOSI SAID WE ARE NOT
LOOKING TO IMPEACH YOU.
I SAID THAT'S GOOD.
YOU DON'T IMPEACH WHEN THEY ARE
DOING A GOOD JOB.
>> MR. GREG GUTFELD, WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THE LANGUAGE OUT OF
THE CONGRESSWOMAN'S MOUTH?
>> I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE.
PELOSI HAS TO GET THE KIDS IN
LINE.
SHE IS THE SCHOOL PRINCIPAL AND
THE STUDENTS ARE ACTING OUT ON
THE FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL.
SHOUTING OUT IMPEACHMENT IS LIKE
POPPING A WHEELIE IN THE PARKING
LOT TO IMPRESS THE GIRLS.
TRUMP IS RIGHT.
YOU HAVE HAD 2 YEARS OF PEACE
AND PROSPERITY.
WHEN HE SAID THERE IS NO REASON
FOR IMPEACHMENT, HE IS RIGHT!
ALL THEY HAVE NOW IS A PERSONNEL
VENDETTA.
THE IRONY IS THAT EVERYBODY
ATTACKS TRUMP ABOUT HIS
PERSONALITY AND CHARACTER, THEY
ARE TURNING INTO HIM.
SHE IS SWEARING UP A STORM.
SOUND LIKE A SAILOR ON LEAVE.
WHERE DID YOU GET THAT FROM?
MAYBE SHE SURRENDER FROM TRUMP.
-- SHE LEARNED THAT FROM TRUMP.
SHE IS TURNING INTO MINI-TRUMPS
OR WORSE.
>> AND YOU HEARD THE AUDIENCE
APPLAUSE.
>> IT WILL TURN TRUMP INTO A
FOLK HERO.
>> WHAT ABOUT TODAY'S REACTION
TO THE CONGRESSWOMAN?
>> I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
F-BOMB.
>> THAT'S YOUR GOOD MORNING.
>> CLOSE YOUR EARS.
SHE'S HEARD IT.
WE GREW UP IN NEW YORK.
THE IMPEACHMENT THING IS A JOKE.
DEMOCRATS IMPEACH HIM FOR WHAT?
GETTING ELECTED PRESIDENT?
WHAT IS THE HIGH CRIME AND
MISDEMEANOR?
YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THEY
WOULD HAVE LEARNED THEIR LESSON
FROM THE REPUBLICAN'S FAILURE TO
MAKE A DENT IN BILL CLINTON'S
APPROVAL RATINGS TRYING TO
IMPEACH HIM.
I AM NOT CONDONING CLINTON'S
BEHAVIOR.
IT WAS A FLOP.
THEY WILL IMMULATE THIS FAILED
STRATEGY?
>> DO YOU THINK THERE WAS A
NASTY PHONE CALL, SHUT UP
CONGRESSWOMAN OR YOU WON'T BE ON
ANY COMMITTEE?
>> I DON'T THINK THE DEMOCRATS
WILL MOVE TO IMPEACH DONALD
TRUMP.
THERE WON'T BE A DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS MOVE UNLESS THE MUELLER
REPORT HAS BOMB SHELLS THAT
COULD BE HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS.
DAN IS RIGHT ABOUT THE BILL
CLINTON IMPEACHMENT.
IT HURT THE REPUBLICANS.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC WHITE HOUSE
HAS DONE, THAT GETS A LOT OF
NEWS AND I UNDERSTAND WHY.
THEY PASSED A BILL TO REOPEN THE
GOVERNMENT.
TODAY INTRODUCED HOUSE BILL ONE
TO CUT DOWN ON POLITICAL
CORRUPTION IN WASHINGTON AND
HELP DRAIN THE SWAMP.
THE DEMOCRATIC HOUSE IS MOVING
FORWARD TO TRY TO SHOW THAT THEY
CAN MAKE HEADLINES, BUT THEY CAN
ALSO GOVERN.
NOW THEY HAVE TO DO THAT.
THEY HAVE TO GET PAST DAY 1 WHEN
THEY ARE ACTING OUT.
>> YOU LEFT OUT THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
>> WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT
>> THEY ARE DOING THINGS
BEHIND-THE-SCENES BESIDES JUST
TALKING ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
>> I DON'T THINK NANCY LIKES A
HEADLINE LIKE THIS.
>> NO, BUT IT SHOWS A
GENERATIONAL DEVICE.
A LOT OF OTHER DEMOCRATS THINK
IT'S A SCHOOL STRATEGY!
THE KIDS WILL LOVE IT IF YOU
DROP F-BOMBS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> COME ON, MAN!
THE FUNNY THING IS THEY SAID
THIS IS HOW THE PRESIDENT TALKS.
THEREFORE, THIS IS HOW WE ARE
GOING TO TALK.
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS THE WAY
THE PRESIDENT COMPORTS HIMSELF
IS ACCEPTABLE BECAUSE YOU ARE
IMITATING HIM.
IF YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT BULLY,
YOU COULD ARGUE THAT IS ALSO
BULLYING.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT CAN
HANDLE IT.
>> SHE DISHONORED HER FAMILY AND
GUILTY OF CULTURE A
GUILTY OF CULTURE FRAUD BECAUSE
IT DATES BACK TO TEXAS AND I
DON'T THINK SHE IS FROM TEXAS.
>> IS THERE A WORSE CURSE WORD
AROUND?
>> I CAN THINK OF THREE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT'S IN THE TOP 2.
>> I WOULD NOT HAVE SAID IT.
I DON'T LOVE THAT SHE SAID IT
AND THIS IS THE STORY.
I DON'T LIKE THE IMPEACHMENT
PUSH BEFORE WE KNOW WHAT MUELLER
HAS.
I THINK A LOT OF HAND WRINGING
ON LINE FROM THE RIGHT FEELS
HYPOCRITICAL.
IF YOU ARE SO OFFENDED BY IT
WHEN TRUMP DOES IT, DON'T DO IT!
IT'S A SIMPLE FIX.
DON'T JUSTIFY DOING BY SAYING HE
DID IT.
THAT MAKES YOU JUST AS GUILTY IF
NOT MORE SO.
THAT MEANS YOU ARE NOT BETTER
THAN THE PERSON YOU ARE TAKING
ISSUE WITH.
>> ALSO WITH THE TALK OF
IMPEACHMENT WASN'T ENOUGH,
LISTEN TO THIS.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ WANTS
TO RAISE TAXES ON THE RICH TO
PAY FOR THIS GREEN NEW DEAL.
BRAGGING ABOUT BEING RADICAL.
LISTEN.
>> ONCE YOU GET TO THE TIPPY
TOP, THE 10 MILLIONS DOLLAR YOU
SEE TAX RATES AS HIGH AS 70%.
AS YOU CLIMB UP THIS LADDER, YOU
SHOULD BE CONTRIBUTING MORE.
ONLY RADICALS CHANGED THIS
COUNTRY.
LINCOLN SIGNED THE EMANIPATION
DECLARATION.
ROOSEVELT ESTABLISHED PROMISE
LIKE SOCIAL SECURITY.
THAT'S RADICAL.
>> DO YOU CALL YOURSELF A
RADICAL?
>> YES, CALL ME A RADICAL.
>> CALL ME A RADICAL!
AND CONGRESSMAN STEVEN COHEN
INTRODUCES LEGISLATION TO
ELIMINATE THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
THEY HAVE CAN'T GET OVER THE
2016 ELECTION.
>> THEY WANT TO ELIMINATE IT
BECAUSE THEY LOST.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING GET RID OF
THE POINT SCORING SYSTEM IN
FOOTBALL BECAUSE YOU SCORED MORE
POINTS.
WE WILL JUST COUNT THE YARDS.
THEY ACCUSED TRUMP OF DESTROYING
INSTITUTIONS AND THEY ARE VOTING
TO ELIMINATE ONE WHICH IS NUTS.
>> I WANT YOU TO SAY HER NAME.
>> IT'S SAVE FOR ME TO SAY AOC.
SHE IS A CARD-CARRYING
SOCIALIST.
INSIDE THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
ECONOMIC SYSTEM KNOWN TO
MANKIND.
IT'S GOOD TO HEAR HER TALK ABOUT
THAT.
WE SHOULD PICK IT APART AND
LAUGH ABOUT IT.
IT'S BETTER TO GO AFTER HER FOR
HER BELIEFS THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
>> 70%, KENNEDY THAT WILL KNOCK
YOU BACK INTO NEXT YEAR.
>> THIS IS WHERE ANDERSON COOPER
HAD TO PUSH HER AND TALK ABOUT
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
70% TAXES ON THE WEALTHIEST
AMERICANS.
THEY DO PAY MORE MONEY IN TAXES
BECAUSE THEY MAKE MORE MONEY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAX THEM AT
70%.
LIBERALS TRY TO DISCREDIT
TRICKLE DOWN ECONOMICS.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS.
IF RICH PEOPLE HAD LESS MONEY TO
SPEND, THAT MEANS THEY ARE
INVESTING LESS IN COMPANIES.
THOSE NEW BUSINESSES ARE NOT
EMPLOYING PEOPLE WHO NEED TO GET
INTO THE WORK FORCE FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
WHEN YOU SHACKLE PEOPLE WITH
ECONOMIC IMMOBILITY, IT'S ONE OF
THE MOST IMMORAL THINGS HUMAN
BEING CAN DO TO ONE ANOTHER.
SHE IS SAYING I THINK LESS OF
YOU AS A HUMAN BEING, I WILL
IMPOSE MY 3W4R50E6S ON YOU.
-- BELIEFS ON YOU.
>> AOC TAKING UP ATTENTION.
YOU THINK PEOPLE ARE JEALOUS?
>> I THINK THE RIGHT WING HAS
AOC DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
>> IT'S ONLY A FEW NUTS ON
TWITTER.
>> SHE IS A FRESHMAN MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
HER IDEAS WON'T BE THAT
IMPORTANT.
SHE WILL BE ONE OF A HUGE
CAUCUS.
WHY ARE WE THE MEDIA, WHY IS SHE
ON "60 MINUTES" AND GETTING ALL
OF THIS ATTENTION?
>> SHE IS THE POSTER CHILD FOR
STATE-ISM.
>> BUT SHE DOESN'T MATTER.
>> I THINK SHE DOES.
>> YOU HAVE AN ENTIRE GENERATION
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT
THE CONQUENCES OF SOCIALISM.
MY FAMILY LOST THEIR LIVES AND
FARM AND FLED TO THIS COUNTRY TO
ESCAPE COMMUNISM.
>> THERE ARE 40 NEW MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, MANY THAT ARE NOT AS
INTERESTING ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
[OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THEY ARE NOT GETTING THE
ATTENTION.
WE ARE OBSESSED WITH HER.
>> THOSE OTHER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS DON'T HAVE 1.2-MILLION
FOLLOWERS ON TWITTER.
>> WHY DOES THAT MATTER?
>> BECAUSE SHE IS TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THAT CONIF I
SKATING MONEY FROM PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES MAY ACTUALLY WORK.
I AM NOT SURE ABOUT THE $10
MILLION SHE IS TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS A RIDICULOUS PROPOSAL.
I COULD NOT CARE LESS ABOUT AOC.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT HER DANCE
VIDEOS IN COLLEGE.
SHE WANTS TO DESTROY THE U.S.
ECONOMY.
>> SHE COMPARED HERSELF TO
LINCOLN AND FDR.
>> THAT'S DONALD TRUMP.